and also the entire workshop so it's my
great pleasure to introduce chile from
princeton university who is going to
talk to us about optimal gradient-based
algorithms for non-concave banded
optimization so please thank you
thank you so much um thank you for the
invitation
i am chile from princeton university and
today i'm going to talk about our recent
work on non-concave bandit optimization
so bandit problems
are known as an online decision
problem
where an agent will interact with the
environment only receives a scatter
reward and aim to maximize the reward
in a more formal mathematical way
oh
so i see
oh yeah i was trying to speak up
so every round the agent will
have some strategy and
sample some actions based on the
strategy
inside some action set
and there is some unknown reward
function and the agent will observe the
noisy reward which is just the f of the
action plus some noise
we usually assume the noise to be light
tail
and our goal is to maximize the reward
and at the same time minimize the regret
the regret is defined in this in this
way which is the
accumulated sum of our star the maximum
maximum
and the best reward minus the current
reward we receive
okay
so bendy problems has a long history
maybe since 1930s
and got a lot of attention because it
has many useful applications including
ad placement recommendation service to
name a few here
in this talk
our focus is to how to go beyond linear
and concave reward functions
because although linear bandit has been
very well studied it doesn't have
sufficient representation power
and at the same time existing analysis
on non-linear settings are just
sub-optimal
we will see that in a few slides
even for some quadratic problems they
are sub-optimal
so our goal is to answer the following
questions
first what is the optimal regret for
non-concave bandit problems
especially some structured polynomials
yeah so we focus on structured
polynomials uh on one hand because
polynomials is a natural next step to go
beyond linear
and with the degree goes higher it will
have better
expression
representation power
and
remember that a two layer neural
networks if you have the activation as a
polynomial it's also a kind of
structured polynomial
and why do we look at structured
polynomial
because if we do not assume any
structure we do not expect to do any
better than some simple algorithms like
method of movement or just match the
coefficients
yeah so
we try to design some algorithms with
optimal dimension dependence for a large
class of polynomials
we will focus on the following types
of bandit problems including the
stochastic banded eigenvector case
the stochastic low rank linear reward
so this formal definition will appear
later when i talk about each of them so
don't worry about it now
and stochastic homogeneous
polynomial which is higher order than
quadratic
i i look at both symmetric and
asymmetric settings
and also noise list two layer neural
network
but it will not be
covered in today's talk since it has
nothing to do with sampling
so let's first look at quadratic reward
which con consists of these two settings
first is the stochastic banded
eigenvector problem
the setting is very simple
we look at the action action set where
the action comes from a unit 4
and we observe noisy observations of f
at
a t plus some noise
and
for the
eigenvector problem the function is of
this quadratic form a transpose m a
where we look at m
to be the low rank matrices and we can
have this kind of decomposition
therefore for this kind of problem we
immediately see that optimal action lies
in the direction of m's top eigenvector
if the topic value is positive but if
it's not positive we can do some uh
shifting so that's not the essential
assumption just for the ease of
presentation
okay for this kind of problem
it actually attracted quite a lot of
studies before
for example during at r and lu at all
they developed some upper bound of this
form square root d cubed k times t
they also conjectured that this
dependence on d is optimal
we will see in the next slide why they
think about that
and we can also see that if k remember k
is the rank of the matrix
if k is 1 then the problem is reduced to
a banded phase retrieval
because we observe
a transpose some vector
squared
and the
for phase retrieval it has also been
studied a lot and there is a lower bound
of d cube over epsilon squared to attain
an epsilon optimal bandit among all
non-adaptive algorithms
which is actually stronger than square
root d cube t regards lower bound
and another type of algorithms include a
eluded dimension
with eluded ucb algorithm
which applies broadly but specialize
into this problem they also get a square
root d cubed kt
regret
and the banded pca
cod cube
some other prior banded optimization
algorithms either they do not apply
or have more response
so why do we have this dq barrier
let's first look at the simplest case
where the function is of this form a
transpose some parameter theta squared
which is just a rank one case or named
banded phase retrieval
so
with a random action a sampled from the
unit sphere
the expected reward is of order one over
d
and recall that we assume the noise has
standard deviation at least other one
therefore the signal to noise stress
ratio or called snr is
at most one over d squared
in the meantime to learn the optimal
reward we will need all the direction of
zeta star
since it is three dimensional it
requires at least dbstring code
so if we played non-adaptively for each
bit as an r is one over d squared we
need these square samples and all
together we will need the cube samples
to learn all the directions
so this is the intuition of previous
result y we have the d cube dependence
but that that is not a very smart idea
we can try to get around it because at
some time we will have already
uh
get more bits of information which which
will help us to increase snr
suppose we are at the point that we have
already learned aspects you can think
about that
think about that as you have already
learned as directions of the sita star
now you can
make use of that to help you increase
your snr at this point to be s squared
over d squared so to learn the next bit
you will need d squared over s square
samples so all together if we play
adaptively meaning you can change struct
strategy based on your observations
together you can get a
a total sample of d squared
instead of b cube
so that's the integration here
uh we assume at this point we already
learned s bits
yeah it's just the the
dummy variable
um and we noticed that noisy power
method is just a practical
implementation
that
help us to
implement this kind of intuition or idea
i suppose people are quite familiar with
power method this is just an algorithm
to help us try to find the leading
eigenvector of a matrix
um suppose we have a random iterate and
we will do
a matrix vector multiplication multiple
times
and eventually it will converge to the
top eigenvector
so
in this case we also want to do a matrix
vector multiplication for multiple times
how to do that is like
we observe that if we
sample the actions
that is centered at the current action a
plus some random gaussian noise
and we calculate
the reward times the noise
its expectation is actually parallel to
m times a
this means if we do the update summation
r i z rtzt
if we have sufficient samples it will
eventually concentrate to m times a
so if we do this update and repeat this
procedure multiple times this procedure
is just similar to noisy power method
and we know that there exists some
studies that show the convergence of
noisy power method and we can
get a good
convergence rate and a good sample
complexity
so
here we analyzed what we
required
so for
for each iteration to get a small enough
noise we will need d squared copper
squared over epsilon squared samples to
get an arrow of epsilon over kappa and
the total iteration because power method
has a linear convergence so the total
iteration is log factor of d over
epsilon
so the total pack complexity to achieve
absolute error is just the
multiplication of these two
which is
kappa cubed d squared over epsilon
squared times some log factor i just
omit here
this will make sure that the
the current
action is of epsilon
optimal to the
target direction
which will ensure that the require
required is actually less or equal to
epsilon squared
and if we just do
explore then commit algorithm we can
easily get the pack to regret
a rate of square root kappa cube d
square times t
that's how we improve the d cube to the
d square here
okay
um
and similarly we can look at another
class of problem of stochastic low rank
linear reward
so in this case the action set is a
matrix where a lies into in the d times
d
space
and
we allow the frabenius norm to be less
or equal to one
in this case the noisy reward is of this
form f a is the inner product of an
unknown parameter matrix m times a
and again we assume m to be around k and
the symmetric but symmetric is nothing
essential we can relax it to to be
non-symmetric um
yeah and
in this case we can easily see that
optimal action a star will just be
m
divided by its norm
okay
so in in this case to find the optimal
reward
or find the optimal action we need to
recover the whole m
but um rdm
also m is of dimension d times d
it has the low rank structure so what we
can do is a similar idea we recover the
right eigenvectors of m
and then it can help us to recover m
easily
so here we will use an iterate x
to
approximately recover the right
eigenvectors of m
since the idea is quite similar i will
not discuss in detail but what we do is
we do noisy subspace iteration this m
this x will gradually approximate the
right eigenvectors of m
and we will maintain a reaction to be m
times x x transpose
where a will eventually
be approximating to m
because
x will approximate to the right
eigenvectors of m
and the whole procedure is very similar
as before
just we change the noisy power method to
noisy sub subspace iteration
and with this two types of algorithm we
can get the improvement like this
so for eigen value problem we also
proved a lower bound of square root
d squared times t
and the gene at all they
achieve this kind of regret of square
root kappa squared d cubed kt
and we improve it to be
a kappa cube b squared times t here
we also have a gap free version but the
dependence on t is not so good
and for low rank linear case
lu at all they proved a lower bound of
square root d squared k square t
where the upper bound has d cubed here
in our case with subspace iteration we
get this kind of upper bound but in this
setting lambda k minus 2 is of the order
k so this actually match
exactly match the lower bound when the
matrix is well conditioned
so this is the result for the quadratic
case
next we'll move on to higher order
polynomials
first i want to mention that for high
order polynomials the problem find its
nature is actually harder
why is that
i just
plot the surface of a two dimensional
problems of this form where f a is a
transpose a star to the piece power so
it's a piece order polynomial
you can see the surface here
for p to be smaller
we have more signal on average
but when p is larger almost all surface
is flat so we have much fewer
signals especially we also observe a lot
of noise
and with this procedure when p is harder
of course the problem is
also harder
when p is larger the problem is harder
and
with mathematical language it is because
if we randomly sample the action on the
unit sphere the average signal strength
is actually d to the minus p over 2
power
so when p is started this is
signal is smaller
so now we can look at symmetric high
order polynomial bandit
but again the action set is where a lies
inside a unit ball
and we observe noisy reward of this form
where the function f the reward function
is summation of lambda j times v j
transpose a to the p power
and we assume those vg are orthogonal to
each other
equivalently we can write it as a tensor
vector product where the tensor will
assume it to be orthogonal decomposable
and in this case the optimal action will
be a star to
equals to v1 the top eigenvector of the
tensor
okay
and then we do something similar than
before
but there is some actual challenge here
so we hope that
with this kind of estimate again we
sampled action centered at a plus some
random noise
random gaussian noise we hope that r t
times c t will be parallel to the tensor
vector product but that is not actually
not the case when p is large
this product will be if you do some like
uh taylor expansion it will have a lot
of terms
but luckily
each term
are all
targeting to steering towards the target
direction
because this is the combination of
multiple tensor vector products each one
will
all push you towards the desired
direction
so with this kind of algorithm again we
can show that it has simply linear
convergence towards the
target direction
and we can show
a regret of this form squared d to the
piece power times k
times t
with similar idea we can also extend to
asymmetric high order polynomial banded
problems but let's just skip it because
it's very similar
so now we look at the lower bound we
want to know if our algorithms are
optimal
for the
symmetric action set we show that
among all adaptive algorithms
the regret is at least lower bounded by
square root d to the p power times t
over
t to the p power so if we think about p
the degree of polynomial to be constant
then this matches our upper bound
for asymmetric action set it is lower
bounded by omega square root d to the p
power times t so the dependence of d
matches our upper bound again
together we can see all the results for
the stochastic settings
so we have looked at four different
kinds
of
problems different kinds of
structured polynomials
and for each kind of problems
the the various works on the dependence
of d
are all
one d worse than the lower bound
and we derived the lower bound
and with our algorithms we can show that
we find the optimal dependence on
d
although for the quadratic case
it depends on the eigenvectors
okay this is our main result
and we also want to mention and all the
ideas can be extend to reinforcement
learning in simulator setting
recall that the bellman equation is like
this so for a q function recall for
reinforcement learning we have a q
function for each state action pair and
the based on the q function we can find
the optimal policy and that is our
target so if we learn the
learn the q function we then what we
want
and this is the bellman equation and we
are looking at the following setting
where we assume so we we exemplify the
result with the eigenvector case but for
other type of polynomial
polynomials it also applies here
so we assume
that the function of low rank
matrix m where and it's a quadratic
function
uh this function is spellman complete
meaning that that with spellman equation
it is closed
and
we look at the simulator setting meaning
that at each round we can freely query
the state action pair and observe the
next state based on an unknown dynamic
function and we also receive the reward
r
at the sampled as a pair
so for this setting we can use the idea
from of from our bandit problems
we can treat that as an oracle
and we can estimate
the
this m
of the q function
and with each time step h we can
estimate this m up to an epsilon over h
arrow with
order of d squared k squared h squared
over epsilon square samples so overall
with all h times
time steps we can learn the absolute
optimal policy
with the
sample complexity which is this previous
one times another
h in contrast existing work requires d
cube times h cubed over epsilon squared
so we improve a factor of d when k is
small when it is well structured
however this previous result is for
online setting we do not know yet how to
apply our result to online setting
because unlike banded or the
simulator setting we cannot freely
sample the state action pairs for online
settings
in conclusion
we have find optimal regret for
different types of polynomial reward
functions
including stochastic banded eigenvector
stochastic low rank linear reward
and higher order homogeneous polynomials
and the noiseless two-layer neural
network i didn't did not mention today
but you can refer to our paper if you
are interested
and the take away messages
the following
first
like ucp algorithms
they are optimistic algorithms but they
can't have sub-optimal regret here
so from time to time we may need to
place up optimally to achieve the
overall optimality
and
for a degree p polynomial the initial
snr is already 1 over d to the p power
so in order to get a dependence of d to
the p
we will need some algorithm that is a
linear or super linear convergence rate
to get around optimal
to get the optimal dependence on d
and also since the initial phase is the
hardest
we need to play adaptively and also
consider some burning algorithms which
means we have some strategy at first
once we get more signals we change to
another strategy and we have also
studied that which will give us a better
regret
in some situations
and also
in this in this work we are considering
convex and continuous action set
so it still have square root t pack to
regret conversion with etc
however for discrete and finite action
set we don't know yet how to
deploy our algorithms
so for future direction naturally
one is to settle whether the condition
number dependence is necessary we kind
of believe if we want to achieve the
optimal dependence on d the condition
number is somewhat inevitable
since you can
infer it from
optimization problems
and how to apply the results for
non-example higher order polynomials
and also for discrete action set i just
described the challenge
and we conjecture that this idea can be
extended to multitask representation
learning for band data mdps
and that's all of the talk thank you for
listening
thank you chiefer a nice talk
are there any questions
yeah very nice talk so i wonder you know
i wasn't how did you do exploration i
maybe i missed that part do you need to
do any exploration
oh
it's just
explore then commit
so the
the noisy power method phase is the
exploration
oh okay so it's x
explode and commit yeah yeah explore
then commit
more questions
um so maybe uh i have one um
so beyond polynomials i mean is there
any is there any other structural family
that you can you know that is reasonable
uh where maybe analyzing these questions
would make sense
uh yes of course there are a lot of
other types of algorithm of functions we
want to explore
um
but currently it's very hard you see
since previously even the quadratic kc
did not get the optimal
um
rate so
i think to look beyond that first we can
look at non-homogeneous cases
and also and then to other more
complicated functions but
it might be hard to directly look at
very complicated reward functions
yeah
and i guess
so i mean one of the themes in the
workshop is also
optimization on manifolds um
is there anything in that direction that
perhaps could be of interest to you know
the people who do optimization or
manifolds
that you could perhaps envision or that
you were curious about
sorry i think the last part um
i didn't hear oh uh i just asked about
you know if if it could be perhaps
meaningful to consider some of these
problems on manifolds
um given that maybe i mean as your state
uh uh your action space
and i i mean and just speculating given
that the one of the topics of the
workshop is optimization manifolds
uh i see um good point um although the
the cases i'm looking at right now for
quadratic or quadratic function making
value problems they have their uh
field values in like uh online
recommendation system etc uh
i'm not sure if the manifold case
applied to a real scenario so
um so i actually haven't think about
that
thank you for the question
all right so let's thank chi again for a
nice talk
and i wonder if
any of the organizers want to say
final words
we should all thank elena for not only
all the groundwork but also putting
together a very coherent program
[Applause]
it remains for me to thank also santosh
and philippe for for lots of help in
putting all of this together and thank
you all for
showing up to this workshop i hope there
was something useful for everyone and
we saw many interesting open
questions and for people who are
participating in the program these are
all on discord so i hope that
there is also some nice work that is
going to come out of all these
discussions so thank you all and
we'll all keep in touch i hope